one more drink one more
drink you know in the morning
for sure we gonna stink one more
round one more round
it's
[Music]
this is what we do catch up for a few
we'll riff and talk some [ __ ] and then
we'll sleep till too
[Music]
let's rock remember that al bundy man
classic did you watch that oh sure
great one-liners man i know ron levitt
like he he said he made that show and he
was like no one will ever watch this
doesn't get canceled in a week
it did like nine seasons great i mean
dude
that's like the all-time great come in
and be a great uh character jefferson
he replaced he replaced the character
and became more popular than the guy
replaced that never happens
oh ted mcginley the handsome guy yeah
yeah
yeah he was good uh darcy was good
applegate
peggy was good katie seagal is on like
10 shows now
still hot still hot so milfy with the
high hair and the
the weird heels yeah the new show though
is it's such a networky show it's like
it's like it's like it's like a lawyer
whose name is like hunter or something
yeah i hate when they do that her first
name is law and her last name is hunter
all right yeah first name is law our
middle name is anne and her last name is
order
like all right we got it a little on the
nose there
cbs it's a truman show was uh
you know he's true man and then the the
the director was kristoff
like christ it's like come on it's so um
it's funny when people do that yeah i
mean uh uh dude this has been one of the
best weekends
i've had maybe in a year maybe
i mean the the the comedy club's opening
seeing the pals and the weather all all
came together
so you got back you were we did you work
on friday did a seller spot friday right
i did yeah i knew a couple people would
flake and i jumped in
so i got all the the i forgot to put a
veils in because i'm never here on the
weekends
i got all the people who didn't show up
i gotta love that
yeah seller was amazing so those of you
that don't know new york comedy clubs
opened up
on friday and i my first spot
at a new york comedy club in over a year
was it was jerry seinfeld dropped into
gotham that's right
and he went on before the host because
he wanted to be the first comedian
on stage it was it was a meaningful
night to him and
to all of us obviously it was cool to
see jerry
be like this is this is important it's
cool to see him
feel that moment yeah and uh
and it's fun to go on after jerry of
course of course
and they're already amped up now like
it's not gonna be a bad crowd now you
saw seinfeld
open then the host then you so it's
actually kind of a sweet spot
yeah it was nice man and then seller saw
some of louie
ray romano was there tonight if i heard
rock was there i missed him i heard amy
was there i missed
amy but i saw amy yeah it was great just
seeing the people go
ape [ __ ] when she went on stage you're
like oh my god we are back like these
people are seeing celebrities
everybody's laughing everybody's happy
everybody's drinking
mcdougal was popping love it
it's a great feeling where you're like
i'm so grateful it's important to be
grateful you know
and then the host does like three
minutes before and you're like come on
just bring me up so true i know i know
it's amazing because like this is just
our normal life that we did for
10 years and then now that it's back
we're like
oh that's amazing this is our life
that's just what it is and we're like
this is incredible this
if you take away anything you take away
a toothbrush for a year
a toothbrush is going to be amazing it
feels like you went on a break with like
your
soul mate it's like your soul mate's
like we need some time i need to find
myself and you're like
all right and you're just for a year
just having the saddest sticks of your
entire life
you're miserable you want to kill
yourself and then she's like
get back in here and you're like yes i'm
back
i'm finally gonna get my balls licked
again but
can i just say that back to married with
children and then we'll get back to the
comedy club because
that's big stuff but please if you watch
first of all mary with children got a
ton of like feminists hated they got all
these horrible reviews no ma'am
no ma'am everybody hated uh you know my
mom and she's like how can you watch
this that's
great yeah i was like i don't know i'm
nine this is hilarious a guy's a shoe
salesman he's looking at tits all day
but uh it was so it's so funny how
people work because we just keep going
back to the simple [ __ ]
like look at tick-tock it's like girls
dancing
and then like horrible comedy videos
that are so
broad so basic you know like a girl
bends over and a guy's like damn that
she gets up and it's a man
you know and you're like ah we just keep
going
back to the primitive [ __ ] every time
well i've said this a million times but
ancient greek comedy 400 bc aristophanes
[ __ ] like that it's rape dick and fart
jokes
exactly they're making they're making
the same [ __ ] up jokes we still make
there's a reason they've lived on yep uh
i mean lisa strada that's the famous one
that the
the men go to war and the women won't
[ __ ] them until they end the war
ah that's great i mean that's like
that could be made today that's [ __ ]
funny that's still funny
it's still funny midgets farts
uh sex dicks you're right poo
it's funny that that was such a
politically incorrect show even if it's
time and it knew it and
it's so funny i mean a lot you would
just come in and say [ __ ] like
you know a fat lady came into the shoe
store today and everyone would cheer
yeah almost almost in the way danger
feels like
i was with a girl the other day she was
real loose how loose was she it was like
they were winding up the studio audience
yes
yes old dangerfield joke i used to love
i'll tell you my ex-girlfriend was fat
how fat was she well i would drop a
i would drop a drop of water in her
belly button it was an echo
[Laughter]
my favorite was from meat while he
sparks when he goes up to a couple of
making down the dance floor
you two should go get a room then he
walks up to a fatter couple making on
the dance floor
you two should go get a warehouse
that's a great joke that's a great joke
that's a great joke
oh man but the children was classic
though it was a classic
and and you re-watch it sometimes and
those some of those one-liners are gold
man just a miserable married couple
yep living in the past he was a high
school star athlete there's so many
so that's the thing is he's an [ __ ]
but his life is [ __ ] so right
you kind of have to give him that pass
he works in a shoe store where he gets
abused all day
his wife never sleeps she is hot though
that's the funny thing
i know that he's just they had to like
kind of make her look ridiculous but
you're like she's still kind of hot
definitely hot the daughter was hot and
then i love the the whole gag
is he hates his life he hates his kids
he hates his job and all he wants to do
is sit on the couch watch tv with a beer
and put his hand in his pants
that was the big joke the hand of the
pants he did that in the place we had
woo
it's so good man and so good and
and the whipped huds like you didn't see
that on tv a lot the power woman with
the with the with the arm candy
husband right haircut yeah so true good
point
it was like that that versus roseanne it
was kind of like those were the two kind
of like trash shows that were beloved
beloved i mean roseanne though that was
actually like a really good show
i think yeah it was it was the first
time like a fat family was on tv
and they were trashy and poor that was
great
yeah man
did he really oh yeah they had a lot of
funny writers i think
damn yeah that was classic i was more of
a married with children guy but i
definitely respected roseanne
i was too i i my parents watched it but
like
90s had some solid i mean we had
seinfeld and friends was big it wasn't
my favorite show and will and gracie
rewatch is not great
no simpsons uh simpsons come on
will and grace yeah i never really did
it for me acting's great but it's just
not
it's not my cup of tea no it was it was
so theater and
speaking of norm mcdonald he had one of
the best points i ever heard he's like
this show is supposed to be like
progressive and
supporting gays but they're just
laughing at the gayness of it like
he'd come in and go i got a date tonight
they'd all laugh and you're like
he's a gay guy i got a date like what's
the joke it's like they're just laughing
at him because he's gay i guess
it was just big to get that many gay
characters in a sitcom
that's the thing it's like it's it's
still what was it nbc it's not like
they're going to take like an
edgy take on it you know yeah yeah
totally
but the you know jack whatever that guy
was such a talent
shawn hayes that guy's he's incredible
yeah but he would come in and go like i
got new jeans and the audience would go
crazy and you're like that's not even a
joke
he's just laughing because he's gay and
saying it like a gay guy
yeah that's a good point but yeah that
was the night we had we had a couple a
couple of killers couple great movies
great music ah sandler that was the rise
of sandler and
jim carrey and yes yes and like all the
tom hanks spielberg
joints all that [ __ ] pulp fiction
all right here's a the nights boogie
nights pta
fargo lebowski ah
even like my big fat greek wedding which
is not our cup of jizz but you've never
seen
it was an independent movie and it just
blew up that was back
even like sex in the city was a good
show it was good
yeah i saw uh charlotte in a diner once
uh
kristen davis beautiful woman yeah i was
probably seventh eighth grade i was in
with the basketball
in our basketball shorts and uh i said
oh i've seen your show and she goes
you're too young to have seen my show
and i said oh yeah then how come i know
your husband can't get hard
huge laugh in the diner she laughed
really hard i was like hell yeah
how have you never told me that that's
an amazing i don't know i don't know i
thought that you froze no i was
literally frozen holy [ __ ] that's
incredible it was beautiful yeah
beautiful
that show is like it's funny it's coming
back but without samantha you're like
how do you do that [ __ ] with that she
was like the
she was the wild card you can't do the
show without the wild card she's the
kramer of that show
she was the weird one in the the comic
relief
which is funny because if they do
seinfeld kramer's probably not coming
back
that's true that's true that show is
edgy too like if you re-watch it they're
like
samantha almost [ __ ] a black guy
they're like whoo that was close you
know like
[ __ ]
weirdly provided comfort on the road if
i would be you know if i'm like
scrolling in the hotel
and i miss new york and i just i'm like
oh [ __ ] tbs
you know that's all tbs had was like
back then at least it was
sex and the city reruns family guy
reruns and like the worst
created shows of all time yeah yeah
yeah every show is like one woman who
has like
three guy friends and she's like oh you
guys i'm cool
i i watch sports and you're like
right right who is this for who is this
show for
i drink beer i'm wearing a jersey and a
baseball hat
yeah that's so true but they every now
and then tbs would have like a back to
the future marathon they'd play
shawshank redemption four times a day or
casino
or breakfast club it felt like a friend
who had great taste and stuff but then
when he was like
i want to tell you a joke you're like
[ __ ] all right yeah
yeah yeah just stick to telling me uh
the the carlin bit
shawshank's a tough one not to watch if
it's on tv is that is that
what's like what's your if it's on tv
you're watching in movies
i mean i'm a casino i just always watch
it no matter where it is
all the scorsese casino is so watchable
for sure it's
it's like a three-hour violent music
video it's kind of yeah
and it's every character is so hateable
that it's that they become kind of
likeable
i know i know i love it i love that
fight in the desert where they're like
you [ __ ] you jew bastard you
piece of [ __ ]
and he's like i know i knew you
shouldn't come out here and it's like
real so realistic they seem like real
friends it's amazing yeah dude pesci's
so good in that movie frank vincent
right that is [ __ ] that was
james woods oh sharon stone
uh
kevin pollock damn a lot of comedians in
there
a lot of comedians yeah it's vegas baby
love it and then uh
yeah you said breakfast club too for
sure yeah
no country for old men that that was on
hbo a lot for a while and i would just
i would watch the last 10 minutes the
first 10 minutes i mean i i
no matter where it was i would watch it
yeah the cone brothers are kind of
you can't do wrong yeah they had a
couple of rom-com
things intolerable cruelty i even liked
that one
i like that one because clooney's so
damn charming
he's got that cary grant thing man he's
the best but uh
dude javier bardem in no country is so
[ __ ] scary so scary and so good
that damn cow thing with the [ __ ]
wait a minute are you drinking
non-booze no no i got a i got a hot todd
dog
oh nice
i was worried you were going uh sober on
us no no no
it's hurting me just for the record i do
have some sort of uh
reflux going on right here and i'm still
powering through for the pod
so all right what yeah what do you got a
hot toddy what is that bourbon and
honey i just did hot water i think
you're supposed to do lemon juice but i
can't take that for the
acidity so i just did bourbon water and
uh
a little honey yeah all right all right
i love the gentle alcoholic i can't take
the acidity i'll just have the poison
[Laughter]
what do you got i got the old-fashioned
couple ice cubes you know manhattan
manhattan i'm sorry manhattan jeez
you're right
what you got from uh from the courier
fireside
cocktails baby they sent us a bottle of
manhattan and i'm not a huge
mixer guy you know you get the margarita
mix or the bloody mary mix i want to
make my own goddamn cocktail
but this [ __ ] tastes damn good and it
tastes like a manhattan
yeah well they sent us dad and they sent
the negroni too right so
yeah so it's just a bottle but it's just
mixed yeah
it's pre-mixed you just pour it over ice
with the bourbon in there
already and i wish i had a garnish but
it i
i get worried these bottles they come
real sweet sometimes and this ain't too
sweet it's [ __ ] perfect so well done
fireside i hate it too sweet you know
what that would be nice for is a green
room you're on the road they just
instead could i mean you know especially
if you're in like a theater
type venue where they don't have a bar
yeah just have one of those in there
that's [ __ ] nice also it's good if
you're if you're a single chap
and you got a couple of uh hookers
coming over or a couple ladies whatever
it is
and you just go oh you want to i'll make
you i got the best manhattan in the city
and you go in the kitchen just
they think you you come out there with a
real cocktail
it's nice you don't have to buy all the
ingredients you can just i mean i love
making a drink i do love
kind of do it but this is kind of a nice
you know
it's a nice alternative if you're if
you're lazy or you just you know
exactly got a woman over you don't want
to have her waiting for too long you
just
get it going get it going yeah you can
keep it in the fridge you just pour it
over
you just have it straight up yeah yeah i
mean
it tastes that good and the bourbon's
already in there it's not bad
maybe i'll try that next week you tried
i'm gonna do the negroni
i love i love making my own manhattans
is my only thing
yeah yeah yeah it's nice i mean it's all
about the ritual it's like
i had a friend who loved rolling joints
he wouldn't maybe take a hit but he just
i'll roll it i'll roll it or the guy at
the grill i'll do that i got it
i love that guy love that guy yeah i
don't want to do it
the guy's like i'll drive you're like
great you drive i'll drink
[Laughter]
you drive all drink it's a [ __ ] i
don't want to
go so you're drinking the
the manhattan you're a manhattan guy you
like it
oh yeah it's got that just just touch of
bitterness and that
kind of blunt flavor i love it just like
us man
just a little bit of bitter but yeah but
also also very sweet
what uh you're here give give me a peeve
man what's going down oh we're going
right to the peep huh
i mean i want to i want to break out an
email in a little bit i love i love
hearing from the people but
yeah well i had this one i'm not gonna
say who it was
but uh this is this is a this is a real
[ __ ] guzzler and it kills me every time
and i try to accommodate but
all right you know when you have a plan
and somebody goes hey can i tag along
and you go yeah sure
tag along and then and then they change
the plan
i hate you so
just to give you a little context i was
like hanging out with somebody
and i go all right well i'm starving i'm
going to hit chipotle and he goes oh
i'll go with you and i go all right
great let's get chipotle and then we're
halfway there and he goes
what do you think about this place and
i'm like i'm going to chipotle it's like
let's go here
and now i'm like well i i thought we
were going to chipotle he's like
let's go here this will be better so i
went there i'm a coward
what place did you end up going we went
to like a shishi
manhattan taco place damn
you know they're al qaeda these people
you know because they
al-qaeda they hijack planes this
[ __ ] hijacks plans
oh
i like that hate it i hate a plan
hijacker they're the worst
big yeah you came along for the ride and
you went
you went another way that wasn't part of
the plan i know
you you suckered me into the hang and
then you
yeah you shifted the plane right into
the second tower
you're right that's a hijack that's isis
that's a hijack man oh that that pisses
me right off
i know i was like yeah i was resenting
him while eating these uh
fancy 18 tacos
damn so wow so we just picked a
different mexican place it was the same
type of thing you had a meal in mind
yeah he took that from you completely
completely and
i was like okay like because he was like
dead set on it
it just he saw the place he just hit him
like a ton of bricks i was like all
right
like he wanted his thing more than i
wanted mine so i gave in but i shouldn't
have
i should have said i'll be outside with
my burrito bowl
i hope it was a close friend yeah oh
yeah oh yeah good
good egg good guy it doesn't hurt the
relationship but i remember
when it happened i said i'm writing this
down for the pun
isn't that funny i'm more alert of [ __ ]
when someone doesn't that bothers me
it doesn't bother me as much because i
know that i'll at least get the vent
about it here
right that's so true even when a
horrible thing happens i'm like
ah at least it's some fodder
remember when we were real young in
comedy and we were just [ __ ] about
something in the business
for like 45 minutes straight on a street
corner at 2 a.m
and then we just both at the same time
be like all right good vent good vents
yes
oh so we'd spend hours on a corner
that's all we needed
freezing our tits off just talking about
one booker that didn't respect us
ugh and and they're probably a [ __ ]
bar back now
that's that's the funny thing but that's
why you've got to do it because
you don't want to be the bitter comic at
least just get it out with your friends
get it out
and you guys i gotta get it out with you
so i'm not talking to some stranger and
yeah you know dayton ohio and i'm like
this [ __ ] guy they're like who is
this guy he's so angry
because i didn't get it out i got it out
that's what you got to do exactly you
got to get it out and how about
how about when you start [ __ ] on a
guy and they go oh dude that's like my
my best friend that's my roommate or
that's my writing partner and you're
like oh
god that's the worst the worst and you
go
yeah i've done that okay i've done that
before for sure yeah
but that's the thing is like the people
like your close friends you have that
part here's here's a peeve i got
so the close friends you have like we
can shoot in each other and it's kind of
good and
peaceful and silly and when you get
someone ball busting you you want us to
be from a place of warmth
bad ball busters whether it be whether
it be someone who just shits on you in a
way that's like a little too real or
mean
yeah or or if it's someone who's just
not that close to you so you're like is
he [ __ ] with me
yeah that's bad i got i got a middle
finger across the room from someone i'm
not that close to recently and i was
kind of like
i i don't know are we closer in your
mind
or are you just telling me to go [ __ ]
myself yeah
and the middle finger was never that
funny i mean look we've all done it in a
photo
just to be cute or whatever but i don't
know the middle finger
i get nothing from that i'm not i'm it's
not a twist it's not a turn it's just
like
it's funny because it's mean i don't
know that's not enough for me
it's got to be a real close friend for
me it's got to be someone who i know
is saying [ __ ] you because i know they
love me right
it's got to be like joe mackey or
someone doing
who's so bubbly that they're giving you
the finger yeah then it's funny
exactly he's such a cute little guy that
when he does it you're like wow it's
like
it's like a 10 year old doing it that's
funny a kid being vulgar
is funny oh that's that's [ __ ] gold
i mean that's what the little rascals
was and problem child
all that [ __ ] south park south park
yes so true so the the bad roasting or
the people who just say mean [ __ ] to be
like wait you can't take it i thought
you're a comedian you're just like
no i am i'm a comedian i'm maybe that
means that i have a decent
you know did you hear me [ __ ] myself
on stage i can take i can make fun of
myself
yeah i thought you actually like hate me
that's why i'm being like oh okay
right right yes and there's no joke to
it you know like ellen had that funny
joke about uh
hey nice haircut idiot and she's like
jeez she's like
well i was just joking well you don't
know how to joke properly we should both
be laughing
it's just an old ellen back when she was
fun and normal and
and straight ellen had another great bit
uh she would say to her pas
die [ __ ] i thought it was pretty funny
yeah yeah yeah by the way her ratings
are through the floor
and again back to my point it all comes
back to the primitive
two guys talking on a podcast not maybe
not ours but some other podcast
gets better ratings than heard primitive
it's weird maybe i i don't know man i
think talk shows also i don't even
know if it's just her thing i think like
she took a break
i think the hiatus hurts you a little
bit and then talk shows just don't do as
well
it's funny remember how much we would
have to tinker these late night sets and
we'd have to do talk shows
and they would be like this word's
better than this word and you can't do
this word
and now it's kind of the point where i'm
like i don't really give a [ __ ] if i do
them
ever again i dude i had the same
realization
like now that i'm selling a couple
tickets on the road i'm like why would i
do that why would i change my act and
put on
look i get i like the old-fashioned vibe
of it the tradition
i get it but now i'm like now that we
don't really need it
it just seems definitely less alluring
and certain guys were i mean jp
conan was always so cool he was always
so easy to
he would he'd be like if it was one joke
i remember he cut from mine he's like we
can't have you wishing cancer on someone
and a joke
for conan's national audience i was like
that's a fair that's a fair uh
note you know yeah yeah no he was he was
fair
he got it he got us he let us be
ourselves but if we stepped over he was
like
look it's still tv man like you're this
is red
we gotta we got away with [ __ ] though oh
yeah oh yeah i mean you had a [ __ ]
joke out of the gate on one of them with
the with the cabbie
you're getting yeah i probably should i
probably shouldn't have done that joke
that's a great joke
all right driver the uh what is it
called the automatic driver
yeah it was that's one i couldn't
believe i got on but i think
i think we got cocky to point like that
was a problem where
at that point i was kind of like let me
just see if i can get this on
more than i like the joke right uh but
yeah this joke was something about
a girl she was jerking me off in the
back of a cabinet a guy said
he said you know there's a person
driving this car and my angle was man
that's like a great ad for driverless
cars
you know that's great that's why you're
a good comic because
some guy go i got jerked off in a cab it
was crazy this girl's a [ __ ] or whatever
but you had the driverless cab thing
driverless car and you had an angle with
it and that's
that's good writing yeah uh
it was not my favorite joke it was one i
look back and i'm like i might have just
been too dirty for a late night
sometimes you go sometimes they're
they're protecting you in that way like
this is a 5 p.m
audience in burbank and people say like
why'd this joke hit harder they're
[ __ ] taurus
in burbank at five in the afternoon i
remember it hitting i remember being
like wow
like i was on the road maybe somewhere
watching that joke like damn that killed
and uh
and that was blue i love when we be on
the road and we catch
each other on late night or catch a
friend on late nights that's the most
fun watching a buddy just like you're in
a hotel room and you're like
all right this they're good nights in
this you know yes exactly and
i don't know if this is i haven't seen
late night in so long but the member
would be like
tonight on conan it's will ferrell
whoopi goldberg and comedian sammer and
you're like oh
you got to hear that comedian thing like
i know that guy
yeah [ __ ] i do i did love it you were
you were the first
i think you were the first one of my
friends on late night you're that can
you crush your conan said you crushed
oh yeah that was uh 2013. i was 29 years
old i was terrified you took conan's tie
and dabbed your forehead and that pick
was like a big thing
that was a big pick for me that was a
big moment he didn't love it
i don't think so but uh i had to i was
just reeling i was like on another
planet and i just like give me that uh
let's let's keep being funny let's see
how funny we can be
what do you say to you he goes uh okay
don't do that because his microphone was
attached to it so i think what are you
crazy
and then it was so after that i was like
i got more emails about the tie thing
than the bits
which was a little annoying but i get it
so after that i felt like every time i
did kona i had to have a thing at the
end like a weird
twist or a gag so on one of them i
pulled out a 20 and i was going to put
it in his suit pocket and tap it down
and i pushed out and i pulled the 20 out
and i put it back in my pocket he goes
he's whispering my ear he goes you were
going to do something with that 20 word
and i go yeah he goes
you're a [ __ ] idiot wow oh my god
he's [ __ ] great it was lovingly but
he was it was so he was like he was
laughing
through his teeth like he's gotta
on some level of respect because he
knows he knows you look up to him
he must i know he's a humble he's a
humble guy but he must
so the fact that you're being that
reckless on a moment that he knows is
probably important to you
he's got to respect it on some level
yeah i hope so because
i grew up like you'd see gilbert godfrey
go on arsenio he would grab the camera
and go ah
you know and you're like that's what
comics do we get crazy out there you
know belushi's doing cartwheels
shirtless
and so i wanted a little taste of that
but we're so not those guys i mean you
have a little
i mean you're you're such a pure joke
comic you know you're such a
you're such a pure joke writer but
that's hilarious that i mean you pussed
out on the track
it's probably for the best probably for
the best yeah yeah
on one of them i pulled a a headshot of
him out and i got him to sign it while
we were
waving wow really that was a little more
respectful i have that in my apartment
framed of course
damn he's such a nice guy too he's such
a he's such a legend greatest
on my last conan i don't know i did
eight of them or whatever he came
you know he never came in my green room
i know all these comics like oh they're
cool when it comes to your great he
never did that once for me
and then the last one he did and it was
that was nice
yeah you think he did it once for me he
uh he's not i think other shows do that
more
i don't think he yeah but it's like you
kind of get what
well you do that thing and then they
come in and then
it's like you have like eight guests and
they're stuck and they're just like this
isn't what
if it's i bet if they knew it was just
you they'd come in more but they don't
want to [ __ ] meet your aunt
you know like it's a whole thing for
them i remember fallon came in my green
room it's like my whole family
it's like my mom my dad my brother my
sister my agent
yeah that's a lot it's that's their
whole job is to sit on a couch and talk
to
[ __ ] snooki and now he's gonna talk
to our aunt that's just adding extra
work
yeah i remember one time i was on the
road with uh
david telling jeff ross years ago and
and dave
uh you know when when the borgata and
jeff's room
his his green room has got like 40
guests it's like
it's like uh you know family cousins
yeah
two people he met in a bar once two guys
like a father and son he met at a bar
like literally
swimming with guests there's subs
everywhere everyone's eating they're
socializing
i opened the door to hotels room it's
like all the sandwiches are
saran wrap nothing's touched he's
smoking a cigarette he looks up he goes
hey that's a comic
and and jeff ross comes into the green
room with
uh with family to introduce him to dave
and he goes he goes oh this is my on and
dave was oh great another aunt
that's [ __ ] perfect i love it but the
thing is jeff knows what he's so he's
he's dying i mean he's laughing his ass
off he's like he knows who a tell is
but uh so great that's
just a perfect like microcosm of their
personalities you know
oh my god like a window into their heads
it's great
but yeah i totally get it it's like
you're on the road it's like
you don't i i get tired on the road it's
like those meeting boys will take it out
they take it out of you so i can't
imagine running a whole show
oh dude i mean not to be a [ __ ] but just
being on the road sometimes that you're
hungover on that saturday you got two
shows that night maybe three shows
and then the opener gets a little too
chummy and he's like so
how'd you get started and how did you
learn to write and all that you're like
ah
i can't do this right now i gotta go on
yeah it's tough because you want you
they you get like i was that guy once
i feel like i i knew shut up i learned
my lesson to shut up i think
but uh yeah we've all been that like in
a green room with you know i've
definitely there were comics i looked up
to and i'm like [ __ ] i
i want to establish some sort of rapport
here i wanna i wanna be
friendly with this guy but i also uh
don't wanna
bother them i mean i have a story i
don't know if i should tell it about
depaolo
but uh it was back in the day you and
nick no no it's a friend of ours and
nick
and this guy used to open for nick or he
did once and he was like so nick uh huh
how'd you get started like what's your
process and nick's like we're not
[ __ ] chicks we don't have a fake
conversation
you know this is like 2001 or something
so that's our story our friends started
opening for
nick and this guy goes hey i opened for
him once he chewed me out for talking so
don't [ __ ] ask him any questions
don't do anything and our friend was
like okay
okay and then he opened for him didn't
say a word
for like two weeks of opening and nick
goes
you keep your mouth shut you do well on
stage here's a bunch more dates
and it worked out hilarious yeah that's
an og comic
yeah oh yeah oh yeah i heard that i
heard that once a night when i opened
for nick and
and we got along well because uh because
i didn't say
[ __ ] yeah and then and then he came over
and started chatting with me i was like
oh he's a nice guy but he
yeah i i've noticed the chattier and the
more questions and the more
ego on the on the younger new comic the
worse of a comic
sometimes yeah i could see that yeah for
sure if they're
well yeah i mean we're kind of going
over notes they should be going over
notes
right i mean sometimes you shoot the
[ __ ] you know i want to be i want to
meet the people i'm working with for the
weekend so i'll chat with them a little
bit but like
uh i mean yeah it's a job man i mean
we're going over and
we're going over our notes and it's i
like when i see a comic in there with a
notebook working on this yeah
that makes me think like okay they're
they're taking it seriously
i feel the same way i'm with you all
right
speaking of uh taking notes and getting
better at stuff
we might be drunk is brought to you by
blue chew
maybe the worst segue of all time
get more confidence in the bedroom blue
chew offers the same active ingredients
as viagra and cialis put in a chewable
tablet
i just got a riff on blue chew i've
taken it before i did the whole thing
where i called the lady and she approved
it they sent it to my house
it's amazing i mean this [ __ ] works it
works well and it works quick
and even if you don't know you're gonna
need it just pop one
pop one and go to the bar you feel good
you're ready you don't have that worry
of like i might go home with this girl
what if i don't get it up that's all
gone you're like
you're like a kid again you're like an
18 year old rock hard
maybe gives you an extra inch if i'm
being honest really
oh my god because you're so hard you're
not you're never that hard anymore
we're getting you you're going you're
going to the you would take this going
to a bar
on the on the chance you would get laid
you don't think that's i it's like
there's something about mary thing
you're supposed to
rub one out before you go out so you're
seeing people as people
well as i say when i was a single guy i
would keep one in that weird pocket in
your jeans that
that doesn't can't fit anything but a
bluetooth pill you know that little
weird pocket
inside the pocket and i'll just keep one
in there and if i
started up a thing and i could get some
vibes she got her hand on my knee
whatever it was
i would take it then damn it always
worked out but there was never that like
oh [ __ ] i've had seven tequilas what if
it doesn't work
well if you struck out you did like a
[ __ ] honorable rub out in her in her
name
so either either way either way man and
it was like a 15 year old kid rub out
where you light a candle
you put on the porn on the big screen
and you know you got a big wig
sock i'm glad you finished that and said
rub out
oh that's the name of our new liquor
folks rub out uh
we got we gotta we gotta go into that
after this oh yeah yeah so blue chew
they make everything in the usa
everything bluetooth prescribed ships
right to your door in a discrete package
this means no doctors no waiting in line
no waiting room it's a licensed medical
provider and get your prescriptions
all online tell them how sammy
oh special offer for you drunks visit
bluechew.com get your first shipment
free when you use our special promo code
drunk just
pay five bucks shipping again that's b l
u e
chew dot com promo code drunk to try it
free
and uh yeah i'm gonna give it a shot man
i'm gonna try it
give it a shot i'm worried it's so good
that you won't go back
i'm just gonna get addicted to hard-ons
yeah
so we gotta talk we gotta talk about
what you just mentioned
for you alkies out there mark and i were
chatting at the comedy cellar last night
we want to make our own liquor we might
be drunk
bourbon we might be drunk vodka tequila
whatever you guys are thinking
is the best we don't really i like mark
and i think we're bourbon drinkers first
and foremost
but you know i could be down for [ __ ]
to make it tequila that could be kind of
fun maybe we would get more women
involved with that right i mean yeah
yeah
you double your sales i don't know a lot
of lady bourbon drinkers
that's maybe maybe it's just me but i
think you're right even if i don't like
the clear
yeah and also i mean [ __ ] the rock
he's got taramana clooney had casamigos
this is the logical next step i mean you
know a-list movie stars
us this is what yeah so i i think vodka
or tequila could be great i could be
down for that i'm a martini guy for sure
i'll do it tequila i'll drink [ __ ]
anything
i agree i love you know we both love a
dirty martini i love a margarita i love
tequila on the rocks with a squeeze of
lime whatever it is
or a bourbon a bourbon and soda bourbon
on the rocks so
even how do we do this that's what we
kind of put it in
in the subject the the liquor and we
might be drunk
uh we might be drunk pod at gmail.com
but yeah we want to know how to do this
because i think this could be a fun
thing
we make our own booze we start small
maybe some
limited supply thing next thing we know
you're at the [ __ ] bar and they're
like what kind of bourbon do you want
and you say we
we might be drunk on the rocks that's
right yes
i love it i love it yeah so tell us what
if you know a guy who who does a barrel
or whatever or has a distillery
somewhere and needs a
needs a new product placement whatever
it is let us know cause we want to have
our own bottle we want to bring it on
the road and
drink our own [ __ ] in tampa or denver or
austin
that'd be so cool man yeah i would love
that that's that's because a lot of
comics sell t-shirts we should sell our
own boots
corolla did mangria we can do our own
[ __ ]
hell yeah definitely and you could we
could drink it while we do our pod
the people could drink it out out with
us out in the uh you know pod land
we all come together and we're not we
might not we might be drunk
maybe that's the name maybe it's not
we'll think if you have suggestions for
a name we'll
listen but uh yeah yeah this is all up
in the air
all all ideas spitballing so throw it
all at us
but let us know if you think bourbon
tequila or vodka spitballing is kind of
a funny name
oh that sounds too gross it's a little
gross little
little uh elementary juvenile
rather elementary um let's see should we
read a pe from the remember
email us at we might be drunk pod at
gmail.com also sign up for the patreon
as well if you're enjoying this for a
bonus of should i read one mark
yeah hit me this is from gt pet peeve
first off i want to say i [ __ ] love
the podcast watch both your specials
half a dozen times
uh thanks also for turning me on the
neighbor mary bargatsi that dude kills
the
nate's nate's a great he's a great
comedian this one
is more specific to people who have
worked in the food service industry it
drives me nuts when you people
bring out food to the table and no one
seems to remember what they ordered
who had the cheeseburger and then they
just blank stairs
looking around like an idiot apparently
everyone got alzheimer's that is good
the same time how the [ __ ] can you not
remember what you ordered drives me nuts
every time love the show
keep up the great work fellas oh yeah
well said
good call i like that that's so true
and i've seen that and i've done it you
know the guy comes up he's like who had
the
the manicotti and i'm like so anyway
this uh
you know [ __ ] guy parked at my
parking spot oh [ __ ] sorry sorry you
know
yeah for sure for sure i've done it too
but i
also i've i've tried not to do it
yeah yeah i try to and i would did you
ever wait tables
no i did catering for a while i never
did actual uh
interesting awful gig yeah gotta wear
that monkey suit
oh yeah oh yeah yeah and and at least
with catering
every gig is like it could be a bar
mitzvah it could be a
elks club it could be an old folks thing
could be a family reunion
you kind of mix it up yeah but it's
mostly just
it's always at night it really killed
comedy for a while so that really it was
never day [ __ ]
that really sucked man i waited tables
for i don't know 10 years
really oh yeah i mean that was like the
go-to new orleans was all service
industry it was all
booze and and food so like that's like
the natural progression
you just oh i'm 14 i'll go work as a
waiter or a busboy or a bartender
and i hated it [ __ ] man
ten years old the good thing about
restaurants though is the wait staff is
a bunch of psycho degenerate
we all [ __ ] each other we all did
drugs we all drank every night
you kind of hang out and you're like
this weird
group of misfits and then you'd make a
bunch of tips
and then you go to the bar next door and
spend it all yeah
but getting [ __ ] up with the staff is
my favorite part of
staying up on the road yeah you get that
old glimpse of it when you go back to
comedy clubs and you go out with the
staff
i don't do it as much as i used to but
when you're a young comic you're
drinking with the staff it's [ __ ]
it's a it's a fun time it's great
because you're in their world for a
whole weekend you're like wow this is
what it's like in indianapolis this is
what the people are like and they're
dirty
and they're offensive and they're fun
and they're smoking
and they hate their kids and they hate
their house and they [ __ ] hate their
they hate the man they're
oh [ __ ] bill bill's the worst i
[ __ ] hate bill
i shouldn't have [ __ ] him that time
you know ah it's great you get it on the
drama
for sure yeah nowhere does standards and
practices seem
more insane than when you're just
hanging out with food service people who
just say
[ __ ] anything anything they get they
get yelled at all night
and they have to be put a smile on so
when they get off shift
off the clock they are just pirates one
lady puts her leg up on the table you
see the uh
like the the ankle bra ankle band from
the you know
she's on house arrest or whatever it is
you know all that [ __ ] c-sections and
black eyes who knows that really
that was us early on and stand up too is
like you know
we had to we it was miserable gigs that
we'd have to smile for
oh so true so true
and that's what was talking about the
pandemic is you you went back into that
for a second like
i'm in the park i'm on a roof i'm
in a parking lot getting my ass kicked
but you just got to push through
got to push through you want to read
another peeve oh yeah sure
what do you got i got skyler lutz
i'm a guy and here's my pee i'm a guy
here's my beef yeah great name skyler's
cool
then he lets you down with lutz
30 rock man lutz that's the cat you
never watched 30 rock
yeah who is that is that uh he's the
writer on the show
who's like the yeah yeah who's uh not
he's
in the writers room judah twofer and uh
lutz
yeah twofer by the way you could never
do that now nah
um yeah skyler lutz i'm a guy and here's
my peeve
women on first date who tell you they
want a man who knows what they want
but then he's your [ __ ] car when you
tell her she's not what you want
shaking my head peace skyler
jeez this is a personal peeve
yeah this is clearly a specific woman
he's pissed about
they tell you so they they tell you what
they want in a man but then they
yeah hold on let me reread that a woman
on a first date who tells you
what they want they want a man who knows
what they want
but then keys your [ __ ] car when you
tell them you don't want them
jeez that's kind of funny that's a good
point yeah like he's like
i know what i want and it's not you yeah
that's a weird thing i've noticed on
dates is like if you
if you don't want to see someone again
sometimes they react in a crazy way
where they they react in a way where
they're they're
they're like [ __ ] you i thought you were
a man you're like i told you
yeah i've been i've been blown off by
women i'm just kind of like take the
hint i don't know like what do you
what else do you do it's so weird it's
weird when they're like
because that happens i think dating
stuff i think people have a hard time
out there
so and you meet a lot of bad people so
yeah
there's a reason a lot of people are
some people are single but i talked to
a close friend of mine female friend
when you know she's
with someone now but when she used to
date i remember we'd like you know we'd
swipe bumble for her and we'd like to
look at the men she would do it for me
too and
yeah uh and i remember she would meet
guys
she's very attractive and she would meet
guys who
if she didn't want to see them again
they were so angry they were like what
the [ __ ]
yeah what the [ __ ] your problem and
it's like i don't even
i don't want to be with you that's not a
that's not a personal
of course i guess you're taking it
personally but it's like
you could be great i've met people that
are great that i don't want to be with
it doesn't mean you're not great just
not for me yeah
yeah no but people do get mad about that
and they get it's almost kind of babyish
and i think and this is this sounds like
a bit but
i think a lot of guys get hurt up front
you know like you ever see that guy who
goes up and hit on a girl and she's like
oh no i'm good no thank you and he's
like [ __ ] dyke
or whatever [ __ ] lesbian over here
you're like she's not into you man
or she has a boyfriend like relax don't
hit her take it easy
and then i've noticed after you sleep
with a girl she becomes that guy
like if you sleep with a girl and you're
like i'm kind of good i don't want a
relationship right now
i'm not looking for anything real
they're like [ __ ] you you piece of [ __ ]
then you're like i just don't want to be
in a relationship
like i didn't do anything wrong that's
if you use blue chew
see that would have been a good segue
but uh no for real yeah you're right
i think there's something about i mean
the power's shifted you they know that
they have something that you want
interesting right and they're they're
keeping the guard and this isn't
all women obviously i'm not generalizing
but like
but they know that you
they know a lot of guys are using those
apps to just get laid
yeah that's why they're like keeping a
go how many profiles you see we're like
not here to hook up which by the way
it's like i've been on dates where
they're like
you are not getting laid tonight i'm
like you're the one who keeps bringing
it up by the way i haven't brought it up
uh that's when you know you're getting
laid by the way exactly
exactly like you're not getting laid do
you want to come back to my apartment
i'm like all right
are you sure do not [ __ ] yeah
they changing the lingerie you were not
getting lucky tonight mister
all right all this this is happening all
right totally yeah
well um yeah there is
you're right yeah i think the the it's
shift there's been a shift yes
once you've gotten laid but biologically
are more
invested before they've before they
have sex and women are more invested
after i think that's supported by
science i think
i i agree but how come we're the bad guy
just because you're upset doesn't mean
i'm wrong i don't know i think it's
depends i think it depends how you go
about it but sometimes you just get
someone who's just like mad i mean
sometimes you get people sometimes you
get people at a bad time like sometimes
i'm just not there yet
and it's not has nothing to do with the
woman like i can meet someone awesome
but sometimes
i'm just not over over the last person
you know
yeah but also i mean just to
back it up it's kind of sad that there's
a power shift
after you have sex like
i don't know why don't you uh
i mean is that it just the sex thing i
don't know
this is going to sound insane i think it
depends what's inside i'm so soon
yeah i mean it was definitely people
that i've like slept with and i've been
like well i want to sleep with you again
i think sometimes they still have the
power i don't think it's always the case
but i think
i think once a guy knows that he got
that they become
cocky they become a little cut like i'll
give an example my friend
i had lunch with my friend this weekend
and he came into the city
uh he's staying at the city right now
but he came in
to meet this girl for brunch and i think
he just they've hooked up before
so he just assumed they were gonna hook
up and i was like
you tried so much harder to get laid
before
with her yes you were taking her nice
dinners yeah you took her out for
breakfast
and he thought she was just going to
invite you back like that that's all i'm
saying
you you're not trying anymore right
right
but here's what i think that's that's
part of the shift too is once you've
gotten it like
you're doing those nice dinners then
what's date three
you want to watch a movie at my place
sex becomes kind of the goal
of course oh it's definitely the goal
but
what's he did something to get laid he
won her over
he he impressed her he was charming he
was whatever
he had a funny story he was funny he was
great intelligent whatever
what did she do besides the sex to keep
him
that's my point
i don't know yeah i don't know i think
but
that feels more equality-ish to me it's
like yeah we you both got laid
and now he's over it but
what are you doing to hold on to him
like it's i have an old joke about like
this is when your [ __ ] kicks in ladies
after you sleep with a guy
you gotta you gotta bring on the charm
now
that's kind of the interesting thing
where like when you see it switch it's
kind of funny
like like i'll give you like an app like
bumble
where the women have to make the first
move and then you see some of the corny
[ __ ] they come at and i'm like oh it's
horrific
i'm not gonna act like i haven't said
some bad openers but like i've gotten
some i've gotten some
turds okay i've gotten some that i'm
like you're hot and i still can't
right back because this is brutal this
is brutal
i've had to say how's your tuesday going
oh
that's it i'm i'm fine with that i'm
talking about like like an overly like a
written shitty one i don't care like
how's your day that's fine that's i
don't know
how's your day why it's a nice nice
break so stock
like you're this is your opener this is
it this is your big
shot is your elevator pitch how's your
day going maybe it's not an elevator
pitch maybe she's writing 10 of them you
know
well that okay that's that too but like
let's say you go up to a girl at a bar
she's a beautiful woman sitting in a bar
you go how's your day going
if she was like i don't know i'd be like
yeah good point that was a bad opener
well
good good point that is a good point
that's not a great opener and i'm not
saying
i'm not saying i need a big opener i'm
just saying like this is your chance
your shot your first app where you're
the first initiator it's a big
power shift big cultural shift that's it
come on but somewhat but someone tries
too hard i'm put off if it's too much if
i if it's too much effort
if someone just hits me with a sup i'm
like ooh
she doesn't give a [ __ ] i'm listening
yeah yeah yeah well you've got some
stuff with that too you like a
do like a real uh i don't wanna i don't
wanna you know
decent woman here i wanna i wanna
tortured i like a real see you next
how's your tuesday
yeah for example
uh that's uh what's interesting because
you're like now i'm intrigued
something very like lowest effort ever
um yes i do think but do you think
there's some women out there who just
want to [ __ ]
i mean i think there's some women
because because you're saying like they
lose the power maybe they keep the power
because they they were good
and they know you want to come back for
more if you're a great restaurant
and i buy a slice of pizza there and
it's a damn good pizza
you don't lose your power i'm like [ __ ]
i want to get more pizza no
i'm with you i'm with i'm completely
with you and that's great too i'm all
for
like anti-slut-shaming and all that like
let's all [ __ ] that's all we're here for
let's do it
if you were the classic one you did a
classic [ __ ] spit your [ __ ] spit back in
the day
oh thanks yeah i'm all for that but uh
i don't know nikki glazer once confided
in in
in all of us we did a live podcast and
she was she was killing by the way she's
so funny like off the cuff she killed
yeah incredible and she was
yeah she's a killer she's a beast but
she was like we were talking about she
she could be like she could be like a
female howard stern type she's got like
that ability for sure
great on radio great on stage she's got
some great jokes
but she's so loose and comfortable and
she keeps it real
which yeah i feel like a lot of people
don't do and she was saying how look
it's just
biological when you [ __ ] a lady they
feel this weird connection because in
your mind
subconsciously or whatever it is you're
like oh i'm reproducing with this guy
like we're gonna have a kid together and
blah blah blah and
i don't know live together whatever it
is but like that's what your brain
thinks because we're all
cave men and women so like we're all
animals
and we as men we forget about that
we don't have that don't you also think
the person getting penetrated
is just gonna like you're literally
getting more of an imprint of the person
of course of course don't you think it's
more i do
you've been inside them it is more
emotional yes whether it's a lesbian or
a gay
i mean a woman straight woman or a gay
guy like you
got penetrated like michael che used to
have this great joke about uh he's like
i don't want a gay kid and i don't want
a daughter
i feel like jesus i just don't want any
of my kids getting penetrated
and it's like a great twist and it makes
sense because it's
traumatizing i like a setup that sounds
ignorant and then
and then the punchline sounds like it
makes a lot of sense
oh i love that i love that you bring
them in and then you
they love you on the way um but i think
that there must be truth to that
just getting of course you're getting
[ __ ]
yeah yes which is where the phrase comes
from ah you [ __ ] for my boss
yeah it's like i got [ __ ] by this guy
and you're like yeah you got [ __ ] by
him that's what happened
right right and yet then there's that
weird thing with sex and women where
they're like dominate me
call me a an idiot you know pin me down
choke basically like
this is all very strange that always
scares me you know
yeah my girl's into that [ __ ] really
that scares me ah that's fun it's fun to
yeah you play the role you go with it
you get them you get wrapped up in the
moment
it took me a while i was not good at it
because we're such comics i could just
feel
like people making fun of me i'm like
yeah you dumb idiot
how do you like that yeah [ __ ] you
know i didn't know what to say but she's
like come on be mean
i do other i do different role plays
yeah what do you do you go the other way
you're very nice
guy who comes really quickly and then
goes i'm sorry
i was doing a character i thought you
liked it
but i see jizz there i commit
um no i yeah i don't know yeah i don't
know
everybody's got their [ __ ] everybody's
got their thing things turned people on
like i'm not into that like i had a girl
trying to choke me once i was like ah
please stop that yeah it's not really my
thing
no no did we ever get your peeve
my peeve oh you the middle finger thing
i got a couple i wrote a couple down i
got i got more let me see what i got oh
please hit me i love a piece
oh this is one when people are late but
it's deeper than just this it's more
than just people being late
it's uh it's rude like i have a friend
he'll be like
30 minutes late for something he'll just
be like and i'll be waiting on the
street and he's like running late and
i'm like
yeah i know
you're just telling me what i already
know like tell me when you'll be there
is what i want you know like yes
we know you're late give me information
you're just giving me
it's like hey uh you're giving me
confirmation that i'm like i'm aware i
know what you're doing
right yeah that is that's a peeve
punctuality is important
oh i don't want to say all right
afterwards yeah i've been the late guy
many times and i learned
just text before you know well yeah but
you always text
you gotta text you gotta tech and it's
scary and i get this guy because when
you text her like oh he's gonna be mad
but it's still
less mad than they would be later
yeah i just try to be i try to be
punctual i realize
like you know i'm i put a lot of [ __ ]
off
yeah so i so that's that's where i get
screwed a little bit but uh
do you really like the gym or writing or
everything
yeah and i want to do stuff when i yeah
i want to get a
quick you know exercising or whatever
but uh i'm the same way
i want to have new bit then i'm mad i'm
at the cellar tonight and have enough
new jokes
right isn't that funny how that works
like i'll sit on the couch and be like i
gotta write today i got it right all
right
it's two o'clock now at three o'clock
i'm gonna write till 4
30. and then my gal will come and be
like hey we should get lunch and i'm
like
oh this [ __ ] girl i'm trying to i'm
trying to write here
yeah i'm on the couch in my underwear
playing with my balls
oh bundy man yeah yeah yeah
you so do you get the launcher do you do
not do that
i get the lunch and then i go hey i i
make her feel bad i'm such an [ __ ]
i'm like ah
you know i'm supposed to be writing but
i'll go to lunch with you and she's like
oh geez
sorry and i'm like i could have just
said no and i gotta write but i i
passive aggressive did you're a people
pleaser i know but then you end up not
pleasing
them because now i'm at lunch being a
[ __ ] yeah because you're
you're you're in a crank i do that too
though i'll say yes to things and then
i'm mad
so i've gotten better at breaking plans
for sure where i just might
i just say i don't want to i don't
seinfeld did a whole bit about
how none of us want to go to your
wedding and i was like oh it's nice to
hear that
that is nice yeah none of us wanna go
i saw melanie live uh doing his comedy
central special
what was that a new in town i'm such a
big fan
i got tickets i went to see it at the
skirball center and his opener was
uh just the fact you're here is a
miracle like
doing nothing is so much easier than
doing anything so thank you and i was
like wow he was
that's such a great opener because like
nobody wants to do anything
and you guys showed up here i'm
butchering it but it was really
funny and and poignant and a great way
to open a special
yeah it's very self-aware yes yes
canceling plans is like heroin he had a
whole thing it was great
it does it's so true isn't it weird hey
just like my whole day
you know why because you cancel plans
and it just represents potential your
whole day is your whole day can be
anything
it's like getting a new joke book you're
like i'm gonna write some good [ __ ] in
here
that's a great way to put it holy [ __ ]
that's perfect it's potential
even though nothing will probably happen
it's potential
it's potential could happen it's like a
lottery ticket
nothing's going to happen but it could
it could
that's i love when you look at an open
day
you get giddy right when you're like i
don't have to do i love doing this
podcast with you but when i look
at like a day when i have nothing no
nothing better
nothing better and you did the least
amount of [ __ ] that day
ironically it's weird i don't even like
there's some days where i don't even
watch a movie
it's so like i'm like i need can i at
least accomplish
nothing right i do i do less than
nothing
i'll like stare at a [ __ ] screen oh
i'll stare like a [ __ ] cnn
screen or new york post screen or
something like i'm doing nothing
yes that's so true i think it's
a lot of people you know you get those
guys who are like i'm bored
what are you doing i'm bored i'm like i
am not bored i can find a million things
to do i got too much [ __ ] to do
i can i can tweet i can write a joke i
can play the piano i can watch a movie
i can go on the roof and read i'm never
bored who are these
yeah bored people it's weird i i talked
to someone the other day and uh
saw my buddy sedan smith and he was like
i was like man i'm hungover and he's
like well you you write a lot of jokes
and i was like oh that's a good way to
look
at it it's like you're burning your
brain now you're kind of like i need i
need to shut it down for a sec
yeah yeah that's true some people think
like we don't think like that we're
constantly guilty i should be doing more
i should be putting on more clips and
writing more jokes but
i feel guilty but then i still i don't
do enough though i still don't do enough
you see you did it you just did it again
but i don't man i'll do like
i don't know do you have a prolific
you're the most prolific guy out there
you just did a special then you had a
roof special now you're working on a new
hour
most people haven't been in the road
it's nothing it's nothing i got nothing
in this new unless you're coming to see
me on the road in which case it's very
strong
and uh no it's uh it's it's just taking
so [ __ ] long to figure it out and
like i feel like
[ __ ] to say it's [ __ ] exhausting i
i'm the same way though man i catch
myself doing a bit tonight at the seller
that i did pre pandemic and i'm like you
can't write a [ __ ] new joke in that
in that year of the pandemic i'm like
i'm sorry i'm sorry
i'm yelling at myself while on stage in
front of 50 people
yeah i did i did two like short ones
that were from i did
i did three one liners over from the
roof special tonight on stage because
they were just so stiff i'm like let me
just
take some short fire ones to get the
ball rolling and i was mad at myself
they're all short jokes but i was
[ __ ] mad same
i'm such a cut to my own brain i was on
the rooftop tonight i did a joke from my
first
album because i was like i need
something that will hit it's quick this
is bulletproof
no one's gonna ever heard this joke and
one guy in the back goes
wow i was listening to your first album
the other day and i remember that joke i
was like ah
wow i'm a [ __ ] i suck
so weird busted yeah i'll do this i'll
do i'll do some i did a it's such a
weird thing but i did
uh i did a thing on clubhouse
and uh it was like for passover it's
whatever
i mean it'd be fun if we did something
on that together be fun if we did like a
joke thing on it could be fun but
overall it's like whenever doing
stand-up on there sucks it was
it was called like night of a thousand
jewish
whatevers you know and it was like scott
rogowsky was on it jeff garland a bunch
of jewish people
on it good luck it was fun yeah but
the idea of it's fun i it's hilarious
i'm like let me do the old let me just
do
jokes i'm doing old jokes and i'm doing
okay
and i do one joke it's a newer joke and
they go we don't laugh at disabled
people
i was like oh man neither do i you don't
you're misunderstanding the joke
yeah uh i told my mom the joke and she
laughed she's like that's not offensive
i'm like
my [ __ ] mom doesn't find this and my
mom is
she turns her nose at a lot of my [ __ ]
yeah
and she was like that's not offensive
and it's like man people are so
[ __ ] there's like a type of person
that's like
they want to be on the right side of
history rather than the [ __ ]
they want to laugh for the joke totally
totally it's like
look we all do we all want to be on the
right side of history but check that
[ __ ] at the door
no this isn't hate speech [ __ ]
these are jokes
i'm not a politician it's a comedy show
you signed up to come to
like get out of here and it's only
comedians who take this [ __ ] like
a movie writer who does a disabled thing
isn't like oh get get the script writer
get the
director it's only comedians because
it's coming out of our mouths so they
believe it
ah drives me crazy we're [ __ ] our
purpose is to make you laugh it's fun i
did a pedophilia joke tonight that
killed and i felt so good because it's
like when a joke like that kills it's
like they trust you
yes and they like you you know what i
mean because there's something about
by the way if a pedophilia joke doesn't
hit you know who doesn't laugh at
pedophile jokes [ __ ] pedophiles
those are the people that probably like
that's not funny that's yeah
i'm uncomfortable right now totally and
and i'll go so far as i tweeted tonight
well uh after if it's a good joke i'm
not saying laugh at anybody
yeah any joke and laugh if it's good but
don't laugh at it it's bad
pedophile toothpaste whatever but
i did a tweet tonight i said after a
show white audience member
that black joke was appalling don't ever
do it again you should be ashamed of
yourself it's 2021 get your [ __ ]
together
black audience member that [ __ ] joke
was great
i loved it do more black jokes i'm a
little hurt you didn't do any more black
jokes and that really happened to me so
i tweeted it
but it's a it's a symbol of
this weird white lady thing where
they're like hey don't do that joke
that's offensive
to black people and you're like the
black guy liked it so
i know you think i'm a racist but you
seem more racist because
you're telling him what he can hear yeah
you're like some weird little dictator
let him tell me
yeah no it's it no no we could talk
about this for ten hours that's what i
said yeah
but uh but all you know the seller was
pretty
was pretty cool tonight it's pretty cool
to be it's pretty cool to be back at the
cellar
new york county man great everyone
even liz the manager who we love and
she's hardest working person to sell her
hands down
everybody loves liv she's the real deal
and
she has some life in her again she's got
a purpose she's running around i mean
she's built
she was born to run that club yeah it's
so true
it's the best club in the world man it
really is great it's four rounds
sold out killer pretty special
great to see sc the yeah the seller
special i don't think we should do this
show
when [ __ ] comes back we should do this
show live
not live but at the fat black we should
we should
this you're in this the fat black right
now folks if you're in milwaukee
the only the only problem is just we'll
figure it out later but like i don't
it might be hard to shoot people are
hanging out there there aren't enough
places to hang yeah
i don't know pull it off but when things
get back to normal 2 p.m
i could do that yeah all right yeah we
can have a day cocktail we're
i do love i i'm down for a day cocktail
i do like drinking a night better
i do too of course because well we're
such
animals that you get one in us and i
don't care if it's two or
four or eight i want another one
um all right let me do it read another p
p from sean
sean page pet peeve i have a roommate
that constantly asked my permission
to use this or that appliance in the
kitchen or also ask if it's cool to cook
something is it cool if i microwave this
or that
which i always reply yeah sure i don't
care every time but
all i really want to say is yes please
by all means cook and eat where you live
why are you constantly asking my
permission what's next
are you gonna ask me where to use the
can
um interesting yeah i don't know this is
weird uh
my only question is that is it is it
your appliances maybe that's why he's
asking
if it if yeah i don't know well this
goes to show that you can be too much of
anything you can be
too mean and eat all the food and be a
dick and not pay rent or you can be too
nice so there's always that gooey middle
and
this guy's going too nice and it does
nice and annoying
too nice and annoying i agree because it
doesn't seem sincere it seems like
they're they're doing they're like
trying to be like get points for being
that nice
yeah totally totally yeah i
i'm with it it get it seems weird like
what are you doing
take it easy we live together he's got a
couple wrecks too which we haven't done
rex this up either but he goes sword of
trust with mark maron and jillian bell
funny comedy about marin being uh pawn
shop owner in birmingham
alabama never heard of it but no
obviously we know marin
um 1917
ah the recent sam mendes movie brutal
action-packed yeah yeah it was great so
yeah i saw that in the theater it's the
last movie i saw in the theater
[Music]
wow have you been to a movie theater uh
recently i haven't
i have not and i was i'm a big movie
douche i love the boot going in the
movies
the whole thing but i know i haven't i
can't wait to go back i hope
that's they always say movie theaters
are over that's going to die they're all
going away and i hope they don't
no they won't people want to go people
want to get out of their house i don't
care how cool your entertainment center
is at home
you want to go out and see it's true and
do things and see
it doesn't count as a date if you take
your girl
to your apartment and watch a movie it
counts the date though if you take her
to the [ __ ]
regal cinema or whatever i mean that's a
date that's a date you gotta tear a
ticket that's the only reason it's a
date but
it is kind of crazy that people have you
have a movie theater screen in your
house basically these people have like
57 inch tvs and [ __ ] now at their house
like poor people do
you know it's it's a different world so
the movie theater used to be exciting
but now it's like
i got the [ __ ] at home and i got food
and booze
so yeah but dude not that i want to see
king kong versus godzilla but that's not
a movie you want to watch at home
i agree i'm with you i love the
experience i love the popcorn smell
i love the weird seats and the the candy
i'm into it i like a movie theater like
there was one that closed
down by me man but they they so uh at
the snack bar they had cashews
you know you're getting a good movie
selection at a theater that sells cash
you're getting some foreign flicks
you're getting some indies
yeah love a theater with cashews you
look at the snacks you're getting at
that bar
you're getting some good [ __ ] if they
get a seltzer gun you might flip there
got spin drift behind the bar
[Laughter]
all right i got a parking pet peeve from
donnie mustachio
when you're searching for a parking
space and roll up on a guy
getting in his car you wait for him to
pull out and he gets in and just sits
there looking on his phone
at least wave at me before you get in to
let me know you're not planning on
leaving you douche
donny yeah this is not i don't really
relate to this one because
city guy but i yeah it sounds like a
douche move yeah that is interesting
i get it because two things one
sometimes people
feel like oh this guy's waiting on me i
kind of like it i kind of like sitting
here because i have something that he
wants and it gives you a little jolt of
power
which is sad but hey human nature and
then sometimes
i do that too i get in my car i'm like
well i just want to look at my phone for
a minute
before i seat belt and drive for a half
an hour
you want to like check everything before
you go you want to put the address in up
your gps whatever it is true
true i get that but yeah if it's a long
time that's
[ __ ] annoying yeah if i'm the guy if
somebody's waiting i'm like ah
i don't even look i just i'm sorry i'll
get out you know
you're a pleaser man a pleaser so
was not a good way people please do yeah
all right should we should we wrap this
thing up uh i i could read ten more
emails
oh yeah let's just should we should we
do one let's do one more email we should
do our rex and our jokes too
oh jeez i've been i've been rambling i'm
sorry
well it's been fun man yeah what uh
what do you got for a wreck well i'm
20 minutes into this tina turner doc and
i'm loving it
oh [ __ ] hbo's got so much good [ __ ]
hbo is killing it hbo is always the best
network netflix has a lot of stuff i get
it but they have a lot of [ __ ] too i
feel like
hbo is top tier [ __ ] to good
whereas netflix is like the [ __ ] out
weighs the good
yeah man i was i've not seen i saw the
trailer for it look great
oh man i mean they go all in on ike
hitting her and everything and he's
he's no joke damn i'm
my wreck was also hp i was gonna go q
and on doc
tell me about that it's great i don't
even know
i don't even know if it's that well made
a dock it doesn't really have like a
focus point but it's
the characters are so [ __ ] weird yeah
and it's the first time watching
anything where i'm
looking at people on screen where i feel
decent about my posture these people are
[ __ ]
disasters uh no it's it's good it's what
it's
it's fascinating man it's uh
it's all over the place there's people
that made this weird website 8chan
you know in the philippines and yeah
they did a new york time thing about it
a while back
but uh they go into pretty hardcore
detail and the people like there's like
four characters that could be bond
villains in this [ __ ]
like there's so many it's it's worth a
check it's like i think
four up i think they just released the
last two tonight so maybe i'll watch
them before
before bed all right oh it's a series
yeah it's i think six parts total it's
good though
it flies by q is at a moment q is like
they were this weird fringe psycho group
and now it's like
it's on cnn talks about them they're in
their documentary it's kind of in the
mainstream
yeah matt ruby had a great line the
other night he called uh he called
free britney gay queuing on
that's funny yeah that's good oh it's
good it's worth the watch man i dug it i
don't want to give away too much but
it's
it's it's solid you got it you got a bit
i got a bit
um tell me to go [ __ ] myself if this has
been done
but uh so it's a it's a kind of a
layered bit about how
sex workers that's like a real weird new
push like supporting sex workers which i
like
because sex workers are the only thing
people give money to
that they're quiet about you know it's
like oh i love blm or i love
trans rights or i love whatever climate
change so they have to let you know that
they're giving money to it but sex
workers are like
i'm gonna keep this one quiet you know
like i'm giving i've been giving one of
them for decades
haven't told anyone what a hero i'm an
activist i'm giving out jobs something
to that
it's fascinating i like that a lot i
think there's something about
a lot of people who support sex workers
with their like i support sex workers
like yeah we already know we can tell
right wearing sweatpants on a wednesday
we already uh
that's the uniform of the i support sex
workers
yes it is funny that it's like
you know man so there's this basketball
player i'm going i'm going in another
direction i'm coming right back
paul pierce uh he he went on instagram
live and he's smoking a blondies with
all these
strippers and he works for espn you know
which is disney
oh yeah and he's getting in trouble for
it he's just casually hanging out
but then it's like you punish him you're
kind of being like
you hung out with not people yes
so there's something [ __ ] up about
that i think i too completely agree
um women do it too women are like these
sex workers are abused
and you're like yeah i got two last
night they're like whoa easy creep like
wait i thought they were a hero i
thought i was a hero like i'm helping
them
it's a weird it's a weird rare it's a
gray area it's a grey area which is
great for comedy
so that that's the bit i think maybe the
difference
is that a lot of people who i think got
into sex work
there's some trauma but [ __ ] you could
say the same about comedy right
i mean yeah yeah of course
or any form of entertainment yeah
politics anything yeah i get this trauma
but i didn't that's not me
i'm just giving them money like i'm
supporting them i'm giving them jobs i'm
employing
it's a fascinating thing because i think
there's a lot of people full of [ __ ]
like we got to help these sex workers
they're down and out they're getting
hurt and you're like yeah i'm helping
them i'm keeping the lights on
but then are they hurting i feel like
only fans have gone through the roof
aren't they doing well i feel like every
article i see is like only fans like got
this
this i feel like there's like it'll be
like a nurse and she's like yeah
i'm i can't survive on my nurse's wage
but i'm a uh
i'm i have an only fans yeah by the way
that
that's female privilege guy could never
do that hey i'll show my [ __ ]
can i get six million that's the catch
be outside girl she got six million in a
day or whatever
damn really six million dollars that was
that's a headline that's a news story
six million in a day
give it a goog damn
yeah so it's like this weird thing of
like hey don't objectify women but
unless i want your money then objectify
me and give me the money whatever it is
it's all it's all very
gray it's blurry it's muddy waters
it's [ __ ] muddy man yeah so then i do
this whole thing in the bit where
remember this old saying you hear a lot
from old guys where they go these
prostitutes you're not paying for the
six
you're paying for them to leave and then
i'm like no you're paying for the six
they want to leave they're leaving for
free like you pay a hobo to leave
you know hey can i get a dollar now i
gotta wait for y'all come on one dollar
all right here get the hell out of here
you're not [ __ ] the hobo behind a
dumpster
yeah i got that women in bars and they
leave instantly i ain't paying for that
yeah yes well actually i did i bought
her a drink so i did pay for that but uh
right right but no that's a great
premise i love that angle there's
something there yeah
you're paying for them to leave and then
then i go on the whole thing with that
but
yeah that's that's where i'm at now it's
brand new
that's this is all interesting yeah it's
funny black lives matter
maybe the problem is uh sex workers are
not being
uh beaten up by the police they're being
[ __ ] by them
oh that's good
that's good i don't know because trans
rights matter but they're not being beat
up by police i don't think
but they are being beaten up they are
are they yeah yeah they're hate crimes
for sure
but there's some trans prostitutes
so if you're into that you're helping
them
all right this is this is dicey now i
think we're going in a weird area i
think the joke i think we got i think
the bit is like
that you can it's the one thing you can
we're getting away from the bit it's the
one thing you can't really be proud of
yes yes but then again it's the it's the
only movement you jack off to
hmm right right
huh yeah yeah
hookers i mean we even changed the name
which is a sign of
progress for them it's sex worker now
so they're dev and then with like the
the the shooting they're like in the
limelight now it's a hashtag we gotta
help them
so i think they're getting some love
which is great but
they're the only group that you quietly
support you don't even want people to
know you support them you're anonymous
yeah yeah when you have like a gofundme
do you want to show my name with sex
workers
absolutely not yes exactly exactly
that's funny all right what do you got
there's a lot here so i got one idea i
think is i'm kicking around i think it's
pretty fun is uh
i can tell you this right about uh so i
say uh you know i'm
uh i'm in therapy and i drink so i talk
to professionals constantly you know
uh i and then people compare bartenders
and therapists because
they both listen they both take your
money they both sometimes tell you when
you have to go
but the difference is the difference is
a bartender will throw you a free round
oh i love this
therapists are never like oh you were
molested 30 minutes on the house
oh that's killer that's something all
right that's a new one i think that's
hidden man that's
it's it did not get much tonight the
seller but i think
it it i did i've tried it twice it
killed
saturday it did not it got very little
amazed
oh that's big they they were a little
they were good but they were a little
stiff
took me a minute i tried some old ones
tonight
yeah there could be something too is
like also
the chance of me [ __ ] this therapist
are not great but i think this bartender
is showing me some love
something about asking for the number
right right
yeah both of them are like please stop
calling me at home
yeah buybacks is a big thing like i hear
you had a rough night here take one on
me
but that's that's true there's no
therapist giving you a free session
yeah or extra time bartenders
they listen to you if you go too much
it's a little troubling if you're like
yeah i go five either way if you go five
nights a week people like oof you've got
some issues
right right right yeah you're never
is there a term like therapy-a-holic in
there or something like this guy's
addicted to the therapy
you're an aaa or something you're in
like a meeting about their going to too
much therapy
something like either way you don't want
to
i don't know there's something here
though yeah
ah it's true cause when you get drunk
you really open up
and you really start talking about [ __ ]
yeah maybe you combine it
where therapists should get you drinking
like if you open up even more yeah like
if you're hitting you open up
to a bartender yeah he's got a bar cart
right here he's like hold on you're not
we're not making a breakthrough but this
will this vodka get you
get you into a breakthrough i don't know
but then
maybe there's something about bars have
like therapy
they tell you when you need to go but
bartenders they tell you when you need
to go
there's someone there about like the
boot getting kicked out
about i have
when you go too far in therapy that's a
breakthrough when you go too far at the
bar
it's a headlock it's a headlock yeah
you broke through a table or something
you know like you gotta go but in
therapy they're trying to get you there
isn't that weird about bars they're like
feeding you booze and then you black out
and do
crazy [ __ ] they're like get them out of
here i'm like you gave me a ton of
you you gave it to me alcohol yeah you
gave it to me
that'd be like a therapist going whoa
you talked about a guy
blowing you in an alley get out of here
like you got this out of me
i i feel like i've had moments with alan
my therapist where he's been like oof
really a couple times i i there's maybe
there's something about
either if you cry and either you're like
all right
yeah yeah my work here is done
[Laughter]
yeah oh this is great there's a lot here
and oh how about this
you never tip a therapist if you were
tipping him he might let you go longer
you're tipping the barkeep
interesting
yeah therapist has never said you know
what we got to close up but
come back to my place we'll keep going
all right that's a great bit that's
that's a biggie that feels like a hot
good times uh keep uh
yeah subscribe rate review uh
hit up the patreon which we you know
already at over i think we have 420
people on there brand new patreon so i'm
loving it
uh keep keep keep joining and uh
you know send us an email we might be
drunk pod at gmail.com
we'll read them we'll read that we'll
read more on the patreon but uh
loving this yeah yeah great stuff good
talk so i got a little toasty at the end
there this this [ __ ] fireside hit me
hard
and and tell us about some some bourbon
some distilleries some tequila whatever
you think would let us know we should do
we're clueless we don't know how to
sell a liquor or anything so fill us in
help us out yeah let us know we can do
yeah and we'll start selling that [ __ ]
and uh yeah all right keep on keeping on
keep
trucking and queef it up keep drinking